Juste avant Noël, un bon gars en rouge
revient au cinéma
Avec son nouveau copain Fred
Qu'est-ce que je fais ici ?
Tu es dans une version -12 ans de Deadpool 2 filtrée par le prisme de l'innocence enfantine
- Mais je ne suis pas un...
- Et personne ne représente l'innocence enfantine mieux que toi
- J'ai besoin de toi autant que tu as besoin de moi
- J'ai pas du tout besoin de toi
Tu as besoin de moi pour te libérer une fois qu'on aura fini
Coucou !
- J'ai adoré votre travail sur '"Là-Haut'"
- Pardon ?
Ne t'attaches pas trop à elle
Je préfère les films Marvel
Nous sommes un film Marvel
Oui mais un film Marvel fait par la Fox...
C'est un peu comme si les Beatles étaient produits par Nickelback
Ça reste de la musique, mais c'est nul
T'étais plus gentil quand t'étais gamin !